bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le casque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout d'abord le sommaire de
notre édition du 10 au 13 octobre le
haras national des bréviaires propose un
spectacle équestre son et lumière unique
sur le département
loïc bordés et mode du puits dit nous
présente son programme original la
rentrée sera magique et acrobatique à la
merise samedi 28 septembre c'est une
famille pas comme les autres car
rencontrer nicolas gervais chaque
semaine le 7e art et need à l'honneur
dans notre chronique cinéphiles grégory
fabiano responsable de l'espace philippe
noiret clayes-sous-bois nous livre son
coup de coeur le haras national des
bréviaires donc près de rambouillet
propose un spectacle équestre son et
lumière du 10 au 13 octobre
des numéros originaux haut en couleurs
seront proposées à leur mode lippi du
biberon soir donc vous êtes la
directrice du haras national des
bréviaires
en face de vous loïc bordés bonsoir et
vous êtes responsable de l'équipe
spectacle voilà alors peut-être déjà
avant de dévoiler les éléments de ce
spectacle et mode est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire qu'est ce qui a amené le haras
en fait à pratiquer l'activité spectacle
puisque ce n'était pas votre coeur de
métier je crois non au départ notre
coeur de métier c'est la reproduction
et puis on a décidé de changer nos
orientations et on s'est orienté vers
d'autres activités dont les activités
culturelles et plus particulièrement le
spectacle en 2007 on a créé au sein des
haras nationaux une équipe spectacle qui
se produit partout en france et nous ici
au bréviaire il ya quatre ans on a monté
des visites spectacles donc une heure et
quart de spectacle une heure et quart de
visites guidées des écuries
tous les premiers samedis de chaque mois
d'accord et puis on a décidé il ya deux
ans de se lancer dans le spectacle
d'envergure
voilà donc alors ce spectacle là c'est
la deuxième année vous vous lancez dans
un spectacle son et lumière j'ai envie
de vous dire qu'est ce qu'ils montrent
qu'elles sont alors parce que la
particularité en fait c'est que vous
faites intervenir des artistes
extérieurs
alors l'année dernière c'était lucien
gruss un démon voilà cette année qui
sont les invités
alors cette année on a deux jeunes
artistes qui s'appelle jérémy et céline
gonzalez qui sont des artistes du sud de
la france
et puis le régiment de cavalerie de la
garde républicaine rien que ça ça c'est
une vraie première oui sept aps à
rambouillet même si un poste en je crois
on a un poste à cheval sur le place mais
eux ils sont en charge de la sécurité
val territoire
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'aspect
spectacle alors loïc duplus parlez nous
de cette programmation
alors peut-être on va commencer avec la
garde républicaine qui qu'est ce qu'ils
vont nous présenter comme numéro voilà
donc la garde républicaine au régiment
de cavalerie de de paris qui va se
déplacer à rambouillet qui vont nous
présenter deux numéros un numéro un peu
technique de dressage qu'on appelle la
c1 pat42 dressage c'est un carrousel
avec des figures
c'est un peu la spécialité de la garde
républicaine c'est plutôt classique
plutôt classique et on a un numéro plus
original puisque l'on entrera lui
l'utilisation justement des chevaux de
la garde républicaine lors notamment des
interventions par exemple des sorties de
stades ou des interventions donc c'est
pour montrer la franchise des chevaux de
la garde républicaine un peu mise en
scène est un peu plus spectaculaires on
va dire par exemple tout dévoiler mais
est-ce qu'il y aura des épreuves de flou
par exemple voilà faire passer les
chevaux dans le feu c'est tout tout ce
qui montre là la franchise des des
chevaux de la garde républicaine
puisqu'ils doivent être capables
d'intervenir notamment au milieu urbain
et agité aura donc un des modes par
exemple par exemple ah oui alors
d'écouter c'est le côté spectacle
de cette utilisation d'accord ok et en
ce qui concerne donc on a parlé donc là
de céline et jérémy gonzalez et deux
artistes déjà qui sont-ils et qu'est ce
qu'ils vont proposer également
alors moi mon travail j'ai justement
cessé de parcourir les les salons pour
présenter des numéros des haras
nationaux et à cette occasion là bas on
voit un peu les gens qui émergent et
jérémy synnott alès c'est certainement
les artistes révélation ces dernières
années peut-être un peu moins connu que
que lucien gruss et ses artistes qui
font des numéros très très innovant
alors bien sûr il ya de la technique des
chevaux parfaitement dressés qui
exécutent de figure mais en plus il
arrive à les habiller avec des costumes
ou avec des mises en scène originales
serre qu'ils ont vraiment un univers
artistique vraiment prononcer sur leur
particularité elles c'est ça c'est ça et
puis c'est d'aller demander dans des
domaines un peu inexploré et ils ont je
crois gagner différents concours aussi
crinières d'or oui oui voilà ils ont une
telle reconnaissance du milieu
il commença parce qu'ils sont jeunes je
crois que ça va être la première fois
qu'ils vont se produire en région
parisienne mais ils ont déjà fait genève
avignon enfin les les spectacles un peu
un peu référence en france et en europe
il commence à être connu et nous on en a
tenu à les faire venir voir aller
prévient alors qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
présenter premier numéro
alors assez atypique un voile à elle
représenté 1
un premier numéro qui s'appelle la
statue qui est un numéro très artistique
où il joue vraiment en couple je n'avais
lu quelques images ça va peut-être pas
tout dévoiler mais c'est un numéro très
artistique et beaucoup sur le jeu la
complicité entre jérémy et céline
d'accord quelque chose est un couple à
la ville
oui s'ils sont mariés se sont matériels
et autres numéros
alors alors un numéro de danse en voilà
alors là c'est leur numéro vedette
ça s'appelle i -p or ce alors on peut
peut-être dire un peu plus puisque c'est
une battle entre des délais chevaux qui
exécutent des figures des cavaliers est
bénéfique des figures en images de quoi
il s agit revoilà et même des figures
originales qu'ils ont inventé le cheval
qui marche et qui parce qu'en fait
battle ça veut dire qu'en fait pour
reprendre ces les danses urbaines là
c'est ça et c'est une confrontation
entre deux et qu'on les cavaliers et les
danses mais là ce sont les chevaux et
les danseurs voilà ben voilà on voit les
danseurs alors là les danseurs qui vont
qui vont intervenir c'est une
association qui vient de chartes danse
urbaine danse hip hop encore un groupe
local
voilà et puis qui vont se mesurer
amicalement avec jérémy et céline
gonzalez et surtout leurs chevaux donc
voilà ça ça fait partie des choses
innovantes pour voit assez rarement
alors qu'ai je suppose que ça doit être
vraiment compliqué d'obtenir cette
docilité des chauffant qui s'adapte
comme ça ok au type de musique c'est par
exemple spécificité du fâ le spectacle
c'est justement de ce s'adapter à tous
les milieux après avec les scènes qu'ils
ont déjà fait ça devrait pas leur alors
leur poser de gros problèmes aux
fichiers des chevaux qu'il faut ça toute
la semaine est ce que c'est
une race en particulier beaucoup avec
des chevaux ibériques des chevaux
notamment lusitanien qui sont des vrais
chevaux de choses
d'accord les frais des choix de chaud
chaud fait alors on continue parce que
l'équipe est également du haras des
bréviaires présente ses numéros est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en parler
là encore une fois on ne donne pas
toutes les surprises mais au moins dans
les grandes lignes
bien sûr l'équipe du dr alassane ont
évidemment est impliqué dans ce
spectacle a perturbé cette année c'est
que la gare hier on a fait la première
partie du sérail russe la deuxième
partie cette année ça va être un peu
mélangé on a tenu à ce que ça soit un
peu mélangé et puis donc on va présenter
plusieurs numéros aux numéros notamment
qui montre tout le savoir-faire dans les
haras nationaux parce que les relations
200 ans donc on a notamment des savoir
faire en matière de dette d'attelage
d'équitation il y aura la monte en
amazone et on a dû travailler aux
longues rênes
et puis aura un numéro vraiment
spécifique haras nationaux clé un numéro
qui je pense devrait plaire puisque
c'est un pas de cap mais cette fois ci
avec des chevaux de trait il faut très
imposant qui font entre 800 kg à une
tonne jusqu'à une étoile sont pas
habitués je suis pas fait pour ça l'a
fait pourquoi pas fait pour ça à la base
mais vous verrez qu'ils s'en sortent pas
si mal que ça certaines arrivent à se
déplacer placés dans des mouvements
assez assez technique et assez
artistique est forcément un cheval d'une
tonne
place sur le côté dans les appuyer ou
vous qui fait des figures un peu
technique c'est tout de suite
impressionnante
on peut le dire parce que tous ces
numéros sont uniques de cette année
enfin c'est pas des numéros l'année
dernière par exemple
emilie facettes a complètement été
renouvelé on peut également dire qu'on
accueillera des tout petits enfants le
connais club le centre est casé breyer
qui vient qui viendra nous présenter
vous avez travaillé en partenariat avec
le centre 15 voilà donc on l'est on les
faits relatés t il sont déjà venus année
dernière et on y viendront encore cette
année on va là derrière c'est et peter
pan cette année on n'est pas des volets
la surprise mais ça restera donc dans
l'univers des dessins animés
d'accord combien de temps dure le
spectacle monde 2h 2h alors une première
partie on fait une petite pause le temps
que les gens ils se restaurer après 20
minutes une demi heure et on rattaque à
une heure encore une heure de plus ok je
suppose qu'il faut réserver à l'idéal
c'est de réserver à l'avancé bien sûr
donc soit auprès du hamas y soit voilà
sur la fnac et après on fera une
billetterie sur place mais l'idéal c'est
d'avoir réservé avant parce qu'on sait
jamais si c'est complet ou retomber de
vous proposer une autre soirée alors ces
quatre dates puisque ça démarre le jeudi
10 octobre jusqu'au 13 dont 4 soirs donc
en effet le mieux étant de réserve et
peut-être vous pouvez me dire en ce qui
concerne le public est ce que c'est un
quel type de public vous attendez je
pense qu'on attend tous types de publics
aussi bien des connaisseurs de chevaux
qui pratiquent l'équitation quotidien
mais aussi toutes les familles qui ont
envie de venir voir un beau spectacle
je pense que ça s'adresse vraiment à
tout le monde du petit aux adultes
d'accord c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
dans une région assez citadine malgré
tout et c'est l'idée c'est aussi de
découvrir toutes les faisabilités avec
avec les chevaux et en dans une
configuration de spectacle justement
c'est vraiment un spectacle qui est très
accessible très familial les numéros de
deux assez assez dynamique
justement l'idée c'est de cette soirée
c'est vraiment à large public alors les
les cavaliers ils trouveront leur compte
mais mais on peut apprécier une fois que
c'est bien mis en lumière surtout qu'on
met beaucoup de moyens sur les moyens à
cette année aux nouveautés on va encore
ajouter des projection d'image qui va
encore améliorer le côté artistique
donc ça s'adresse vraiment à tous les
publics d'accord mais écoutez merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être revenu
sur cette plateau pour nous en parler
donc on rappelle les dates du 10 au 13
octobre ou haras des bréviaires
n'oubliez pas de réserver
alors on va rester avec vous encore
quelques instants parce que avant de
retrouver donc notre chroniqueur nicolas
gerber nous partons pour rambouillet où
s'est déroulé le week-end dernier le
concours international d'attelage de
tradition organisé donc par le haras des
bréviaires
retour en images d'elodie moines chevaux
voitures anciennes et meneurs étaient en
compétition ce week end dans le parc du
château de rambouillet organisé depuis
trois ans par le haras national des
bréviaires
le concours international d'attelage de
tradition a réuni une quarantaine de
participants
ces collectionneurs de voitures
anciennes modèles d'époque de la fin du
19e ou répliques fidèles sont notamment
jugés pour l'harmonie du couple cheval
voiture marche et attelages en simple en
perd en tandem composé de chevaux de
poneys et parfois même dan quelle que
soit la catégorie du concours
l'attelage de tradition reste pour le
meneur une vraie passion le ménage
permet d'avoir une équitation à distance
qui est absolument passionnante et vous
menez va y ait quatre chevaux avec juste
une main ou deux et vous avez des
sensations absolument d'abord le plaisir
des fans et puis le respect de la
tradition pas ce sont des choses qu'on
doit transmettre aux générations futures
c'est très important
la france de talent pays tellement
accueillants pour les contrôles
tradition on y revenir très souvent
après trois épreuves réalisés de jour la
présentation le parcours routier et la
maniabilité nos deux compétiteurs ont
chacun remporté un prix dans leur
catégorie
nicolas gervais notre chroniqueur
préféré à rencontrer cette semaine une
famille pas tout à fait comme les autres
la famille morallès vous ne savez pas de
qui il s'agit écoutez écoutez les quand
cette famille là vous invite à dîner
c'est pour vous faire des acrobaties
jouer de la musique ou encore jongler
c'est la famille morallès et elle sera
les 28 et 29 septembre à la merise
attraper et croyez moi on va en faire
tout un cirque disparition
c'est une vraie famille qui vient qui
part de la grand mère qui est la mamie
monique jusqu'au dernier qui a 3 ans et
demi et marius et qui décline tous les
allées des 50 40 30
voilà jusqu'à jusqu'à trois ans et demi
110 et mon beau-père en fin de compte
peu le grand-père qui avait monté son
cirque qui a émaillé le cirque morales
et après ça s'est arrêté en 84 184 sar
pris à 97,97 on a remonté la famille
tout le monde s'est retrouvé tous les
enfants et on a monté la famille
morallès on enlevait un petit peu de
mots syrien on a mis la famille morallès
le cirque autrement pasqua on pense
faire du cirque autrement dans le
spectacle d'un diamant qui vont venir
voir les gens ici lé public va venir ici
un attrape
c'est un mélange de quatre grosses ipo
vers le théâtre avec du texte
il y a le jeu de comédiens bien sûr il
ya du cirque les numéros de cirque il ya
la musique vivante
il ya du champ et il ya la chorégraphie
la danse donc je pense que tous les arts
sont représentés dans ce spectacle
il n'y a pas d'enfants dans spectacle
sauf un qui a plus de dix ans et qui est
déclarée sinon on aurait pas d'entravé
après tout les petits tous les petits
viennent un petit peu au début du
spectacle avec nous comme ça en piste
c'est un petit peu pour leur faire leurs
premières armes un petit peu les
confronter au public leur enlever une
certaine crainte une certaine peut-être
peur on veut dire mon sac est pas une
peur mais une crainte d'être devant le
public donc c'est important qu'ils
viennent de bonheur avec nous mais sont
pas dans le spectacle
oh
dans le spectacle il ya bien sûr des
numéros 6 et 20 il ya des numéros ya
comme de trapèze qui est présent il ya
une héros du tissu serre sur les tissus
qui pend de l'eau et qui sont ou évalue
quelqu'un il ya du mât chinois qui est
quand même un travail physique ou c'est
ma fille qui est dessus et qui choque
il ya la jonglerie et la jonglerie à
beaucoup de personnes n'ont à tessa du
passing qui est donc un passage de
massue de quilles entre entre entre tous
les artistes
il ya du vélo vue l'acrobatique il ya
des numéro d' équilibre si de faire donc
fil de fériste qui est vraiment très bon
numéro de fil de fériste il y à il ya
plein de choses de la magie fois là ça
n'arrête pas et au milieu de tout ça il
ya toutes ces avantages ces
interventions pardon théâtrale
je
je t'aime
ça fait près d'un an que ça dure et ça
durera encore oui non non on peut dire
que c'est facile parce que c'est c'est
faut s'imaginer quoi être toujours en
famille mais on a aussi nos petits
moments de tranquillité parce qu'on
habite chacun à des endroits différents
donc c'est bien aussi de se reposer de
temps en temps
bon
il
et voilà le circle morales donc les 28
et 29 septembre à la mairie à frappe
organes et à ses travaux merci nicolas à
la semaine prochaine passant tout de
suite à notre chronique cinéphiles
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d' elodie
moines c'est un très joli documentaire
qui apporte beaucoup de choses et de
connaissances on s'attend pas du tout à
avoir des enfants qu'ils puissent faire
des kilomètres comme ça pour aller à
l'école c'est vraiment un film prévue
tous les enfants le la nature et ce qui
est dégagée dans le film a un super
franchement c'est une belle leçon de vie
par des enfants c'est super bien filmé
alors après match aller lors en version
française je pense qu'en version
originale ça doit être ça donne beaucoup
mieux j'ai trouvé que la crise est elle
faisait une performance extraordinaire
mais je regrette qu'une chose c'est que
woody allen ne soit pas dans ses films
ne ne joue pas génial woody allen
vraiment forme il ya des acteurs
sublimes un très très bon goût des
années peut-être un des meilleurs
munster fit très bien en plus ça m'a
rappelé ma jeunesse
saint geours a gardé beaucoup les
formule 1 quand j'annonce la chronique
cinéphiles c'est aussi l'occasion de
donner la parole un professionnel du
cinéma qui nous donne son coup de coeur
de la semaine
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de grégory
pagano de l'espace fiq noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois l'écoutent
le coup de coeur de cette semaine à
l'espace philippe noiret c'est le film
gare du nord un très beau film que vous
allez découvrir une façon assez atypique
puisque on va pas suivre une fiction
comme d'habitude mais plutôt de petites
histoires de petites fictions et en fait
c'est un peu comme si on avait le regard
d'un sociologue qui se posaient sur un
banc pendant deux heures évidemment la
réalisatrice claire simon nous a réservé
a condensé des meilleures choses qui
peuvent se passer dans une gare des
meilleurs et des pires d'ailleurs la
gare du nord qui est une garce
extraordinaire puisque c'est quand même
la première gare d'europe en terme de
fréquentation
et c'est également une gare où chaque
jour 700 mille personnes décédées donc
c'est vraiment une ville à part entière
un endroit où l'on va découvrir des
destins qui vont se croiser d'une façon
assez étonnante
je vous propose de regarder tout de
suite la bande-annonce de gare du nord
tout
hb non
bonjour j'ai une enquête pour la ratp
c'est une dizaine de questions à vous
poser un peu
profession aux histoires moi je fais de
la sociaux je fais ma thèse je sais pas
si tu détestes c'est la grande gare du
nord
il sort de nulle part c'est comme une
place de village et si c'était un
village bas ce serait le monde
ça ce changement comme une balèze de
venu à paris pour financer
j'ai de gros international s ktm qui
compte a disparu ici ça tu as croisé mon
ces petites choses c'est que c'est pas
truqué
je veux faire rêver aux jolies poupées
un sondage pour la sncf j'avais combine
trou du cul s'invente pas
je suis toujours aussi
beck facile avec facile jadis une enfant
je reviens encore
demain
amoureuse que j'avais 15 ans
ça
tina
avant de refermer cette édition je vous
propose quelques dates de sorties
culturelles
la 8e édition du chantier d'arrêt de
scène à l'espace decaux villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous propose du 26
au 28 septembre un frau un florilège de
spectacles soirées cabaret concert
exposition humour
retrouvez tout le programme sur le site
de la compagnie organisatrice what to do
la 12e biennale mondial de reliure d'art
se tiendra du 25 au 29 septembre à
l'espace jean racine à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse une
manifestation unique en son genre près
de 300 reliure d'art sont exposés et
vingt six pays représentés l'estival
2013 le festival de musique de saint
germain en laye démarre le 27 septembre
jusqu'au 12 octobre
cette année les bb brunes amadou et
mariam stephan eicher ou encore pascal
obispo seront sur scène une dernière
information demain jeudi se tiendra la
journée étudiante à l'université de
versailles saint quentin et à partir de
19h un concert ouvert à tous du groupe
boulevard des airs donc se tiendra dans
le parc des sources de la biette donc
accueille en cours pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ce groupe a été nommé
aux victoires de la musique 2013 était
notamment à la fête de l'huma il ya
quelques semaines voilà cette édition
est à présent terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h30
à bientôt